I'm drew Coolidge and yes we've got the
age of Ultron post-credits scene coming
up in just a second but we've also got
how it fits into the larger Marvel
Universe let's get into it this is
hashtag news alright let's go ahead and
take a look at this mid-credits scene
so fan OHS played by Josh Brolin is a
powerful eternal alien warlord and in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe he's
looking for the Infinity stones ancient
artifacts of amazing power created
before the universe itself and once
their place in the Infinity Gauntlet
gives the wearer basically ultimate
power over everything which makes sense
so now at this point in the MCU Thanos
has played a fairly minor role appearing
in only a handful scenes most
prominently in gardens of the galaxy
these scenes all build upon his ultimate
goal to attain the six Infinity stones
each stone controls the six components
of the universe and it's complicated
I'll just let someone earlier explain it
Thanos as you know owns the Infinity
Gauntlet which has the time gem the mind
gem the power gem the space gem and the
reality gem if he holds the reality gem
that means he can jump from different
realities basically if you have them you
can destroy the universe which Stannis
is all about because he wants to impress
death a cosmic entity that he's in love
with he's got a type but just a heads up
Infinity stones can only be wielded by
extremely powerful beings like fanner
so don't touch them with your bare hands
or you turn all purple and [ __ ] in the
first Captain America movie one of the
stones the tesseract is found on earth
by the Red Skull he gets his ass handed
to him by Captain America and the
tesseract eventually falls under the
control of Nick Fury and shield so in
the first Avengers movie Daniels allies
himself with Loki Thor's brother and the
god of mischief he says hey Loki I'll
give you an army to attack earth if you
just bring me the tesseract but Loki
also gets his ass handed to him
so that didn't work either but the end
of the Avengers marks the first time we
actually see Finn and it seems like he's
in a pretty good mood
later in guardians of the galaxy Thanos
orders Ronan the accuser a rogue alien
commander to retrieve the or a
protective casing for one of the
Infinity stones called the Power Stone
unfortunately for him the orb is in the
hands of star-lord and the other
guardians and surprise Ronan gets his
ass handed to him on the dance floor
which brings us to the Avengers age of
Ultron now-famous is more of a
background thread in this one as well
because as far as Marvel villains go
he's basically the end of the line so
the post-credits scene of him saying
he'll do it himself means he's had
enough of these bozos he's going after
this stone himself which puts him on a
collision course with the Avengers and
really the entire MCU luckily we'll only
have to wait until May 2018 I'll be dead
by then that's it first here at hashtag
news hit like if you still have no idea
of what an infinity stone is comment if
you definitely know when an infinity
stone is and can help out the rest of us
and hit subscribe if you want all the
latest movie news that may or may not
have to do with Infinity stones but it
probably will there's a lot more of
these movies I'm drew Coolidge and I'm
gonna go look for some more Infinity
stones gotta catch em oh no it's my
destiny Thanos oh good my best friend
and you're dating death oh yeah